[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
come on in have a seat get comfortable
welcome to the table my name is Karen
I'm so glad you're here here in this
room and then also a big welcome to
those of us joining online tonight I'm
going to jump right in because we have
three announcements and then as you can
see we have a special setup up here for
worship and I want to give them plenty
of time to do their thing because they
are amazing uh yes first announcement
tonight is first Sunday and around here
the first Sunday of every month
immediately following the service we
head over to hat Creek Burger Company in
Sachse about five minutes down the road
and share a meal together all of you are
invited and we would love to have you
it's just a great way to continue making
connections here talking to people and
becoming a part of the community
secondly this is very important for one
Sunday only on October 23rd we are
having a service time change for a
really good reason we are going to join
in with our host Church Pleasant Valley
United Methodist to help them celebrate
their 160th yeah you heard that right
160th anniversary as a church and you
guys they have been so supportive and
encouraging of our community here we
would love to return that favor and show
up for them so that service on Sunday
October 23rd will be here at 11 00 a.m
so you got to get up a little earlier to
come to that one but I really hope as
many of us from the table can show up
and help them to celebrate and then
they've very graciously invited us to
join them in their catered lunch
immediately following the service so
sounds like a great Sunday to me and I
hope you'll join us for that and then
last but not least you might have
noticed my cool t-shirt
um yay uh speaking of anniversaries the
first weekend in November the table will
be celebrating its third anniversary as
a community which is really cool yeah
and to commemorate that uh we're gonna
do a round of t-shirts we haven't done
t-shirts in a while and uh Brittany
who's right there Maggie and Mindy have
joined together to create these great
t-shirts we have this one uh these are
our values and then we have a second
design which is our table logos anybody
wearing one of those you might have seen
it on the sign outside by the road and
we have them in a couple colors it's
like a greenish blueish this is just a
mock-up just to show you what the design
looks like the colors will be a little
different
and to order those you can go to either
our Facebook page our Instagram page the
table TX and there's a link to order if
you get Brett's e-letter you can also
order uh there as well he'll include a
link for you they're 20 bucks all
proceeds go back into our community to
help others and uh do we have an expert
like a deadline
for orders
October October 23rd is that right 16th
that's right okay so deadline to order
Sunday October 16th in order to get them
in in time for our third anniversary and
for those of us that are attending the
centerpiece conference we'd love to wear
our table t-shirts there and represent
too sound good I know that's a lot of
information
um how about
just with the busyness of this week
maybe the busyness uh of your weekend
let's take a moment to center before we
enter into worship So Close Your Eyes
with me
take a deep breath
inhale some peace
exhale some stress
God we come to you tonight thankful and
grateful for this community God
for Pleasant Valley their community
and that we get to spend another Sunday
together
God I pray that this service this music
the message the people
that we would fill each other up tonight
God that you would fill us up and that
would we would each find what we need
tonight that we would remember that you
are love
that we are already loved we are your
children
and God I pray that you would speak to
us right where we are help us to trust
you at deeper levels to open ourselves
up more to your ways your character
and anything and everything you would
have for us God
in Jesus name amen
thanks Karen I just wanted to take a
second before we jump into the worship
set to introduce some people up here
that you may some you probably already
know
um for most of you this is Ramon and
Miranda Delgado
they have a fan club I mean like
pretty well known already but in case
you haven't met met them before their
fabulous part of our community and for a
lot of other reasons
um with scheduling and everything it's
been difficult to get them up here on
stage but they are just both so talented
and we're so happy that they could join
us tonight as part of the worship set
and they brought their friend Josh Gage
back here and you guys I just have to
say as someone who's LED worship for a
long time I love our little Cajon set
but it doesn't hold a candle to a real
drummer and he's so much better than
anything I could ever do on this stage
so I hope you guys just enjoy the tree
of like an expanded worship experience
tonight
um if you guys want to stand with us
we're going to get started and Ramon and
Miranda planned this set and put so much
time and effort and energy into it I'm
so thankful for them so really and truly
you guys just join in with us you are at
home here and um your voice your
presence is welcome in this worship
space so let's just enter in together
foreign
[Music]
evening
my faith will stand
upon your name yours
[Music]
and you are
[Applause]
[Music]
crazy
and keep our eyes
[Music]
thank you
Spirit lead me where my trust is
[Music]
wherever you would call me
take me deeper than my feet
[Music]
you were gone foreign
foreign
[Music]
kiddos y'all are dismissed to your
classes
and we're going to keep moving into the
prayers of the people
um for those of you who aren't always
here and or if you're joining us online
feel free when we get to the opening
between the prayer to leave anything
that's on your heart and those comments
and we will share them here with the
room tonight I'm going to have Ramon
lead us in the prayers of the people and
kind of speak to us about
um we'll just go ahead and take it over
you can tell them thank you Mindy uh
thank you uh Church uh for worshiping
with us
as we pray prayers other people we were
thinking of talking
um there in the prayer room before uh
worship uh besides these being Hispanic
Eric this month
a lot of Spanish-speaking people in
Puerto Rico Cuba
Florida
they are suffering because of Fiona Ian
and
many other
disasters are they're going through
right now so we thought it would be uh a
good idea since they are also part of
the church that we do this
prayer of the people in Spanish so
as you follow alone in English
in the screen
I'm going to pray in Spanish
so let's do it like that can you teach
us really quick
let's practice one two three
and I will give you the signal when it's
time to join in
Texas
sofrito
yo primido
de sem playado is
it's gonna be
Johanna
Stephanie and Josh
y
or los nombres momentos corazones
foreign
[Music]
in the presence of my enemy
I raise a Hallelujah
louder than the unbelief
[Music]
Heaven comes to fight for me
louder and louder
[Music]
highly
Hallelujah
[Music]
love is Mystery
and louder
[Music]
louder louder
my birthday
[Music]
together
I just wanna speak the name of Jesus
[Music]
I know there is
clearing there is hope and there's
freedom
s
[Music]
your name is
healing
[Music]
good night
I just wanna speak the name of Jesus
[Music]
anxieties
stronger
shine through the Shadows
[Music]
your name is
foreign
[Music]
Jesus healing
[Applause]
[Music]
shine through the Shadows
your name
[Applause]
[Music]
I just wanna speak the name of Jesus
cause I know there is peace within your
presence
[Music]
shout Jesus from the mountains Jesus in
the streets shall Jesus in the darkness
over every enemy
and Jesus born
family I speak the Holy Name of Jesus
shout Jesus Christ
[Music]
Jesus thank you that your name is Love
your presence is love your character and
your nature is love
and God when we meet you that's what we
come face to face with when you are at
work in our life it is love that
transforms us and connects us and
crosses the bridge over to the other
side God thank you for a love that is
stronger than everything we face
hatred
suffering
depression
fear
God would your love have a home in our
hearts and in our minds and in our
community God
would it be love that shapes us
would it be love that we speak to one
another
that we share with this broken world
[Music]
and would it be your love that heals us
God
in our Brokenness
[Music]
thank you for this time together God
thank you
for this community would you continue to
do your good work in our hearts
and may it turn
[Music]
it amen thank you guys if y'all would
turn to the people around you make them
feel welcome and at home here and then
we can be seated and Brett will get us
started on our message
really
yeah
all right all right well thank you
worship team that was really wonderful
and
um
Grace and peace to all of you it's
really really good to be with you
um I want to extend a welcome to those
joining us online
um and anyone here who is new
um
we're just really really glad to have
you have you with us amongst us and I
hope you feel um just a sense of of
welcome so
um let's see we are in a series right
now
uh and it is titled unclean Drawing Near
in a runaway world and um this series
based on a book by the Christian Author
and psychologist Richard Beck has been
about a number of things
um at one level it's been about
discussed and something we've kind of
referred to as discussed psychology and
this is the you know the the things that
we find disgusting whether it's you know
cockroaches or
I mean you know mold on food whatever
you know I don't have to list them all
that was week one y'all were here and
many of you were here and that was we
had to do a whole 10 minutes of kind of
grossness
um so the thing we named though why we
think the series matters
um in a church context is
um the tricky way that we come to view
um not only things as unclean
but who
people that's the trick that's the the
slide and we we named it it kind of
happens via our our moral imaginations
um we we use these metaphors you know to
think of of folks and it's interesting
that certain things we do
um lend themselves to kind of different
metaphors
um While others
um well for example like
um
certain sins you know we start to think
of in terms of like oh that person oh
they're kind of contaminated
you know dirty
um and that's like that's where the
danger comes in
um but we kind of in ways though like I
think on the surface that's what the
series has been about like discussed in
the way that we come to view you know
people is unclean and such
um but at a deeper level
um I think it's in ways it's also been
really just about love and kind of
naming our at times failures to love our
struggles to love
um so kind of throughout the series
um we've been kind of in this like one
scripture we've just been repeating it
at times we'll go into another one but
in ways we just keep coming back to
Matthew 9 and this little story on
verses 9 through 13. and uh this is a
story about Jesus and the Pharisees and
it says this as Jesus went on from there
he saw a man named Matthew
sitting at the tax collector's booth
follow me he told him and Matthew got up
and followed him while Jesus was having
dinner at Matthew's house many tax
collectors and sinners came and ate with
him and his disciples when the Pharisees
saw this they asked his disciples why
does your teacher eat with tax
collectors and sinners you can hear it
right there right like oh why why is
eating with them you know those people
those kinds of people the the morally
questionable ones right
on hearing this Jesus said
it is not the healthy who need a doctor
but the sick
but go and learn what this means I
desire Mercy not sacrifice for I have
not come to call the righteous but
sinners
so we are we're in week four of this
series
and
I think
um
lurking kind of in the background there
might have
be a question in the back of your mind
and um
let me set it up this way you know so
this Series has been everything I just
named everything that story communicates
and in ways it's really been
um
about a call to a radical love that
crosses the chasms that crosses
um boundaries it's it's really been
um about a kind of an invitation to a
not just a radical Hospitality but
whatever a extra double radical I mean
it's like it just incredibly radical
hospitable welcome
that just does its best not to
um see people through these sort of
moral lenses and and judgment and that
you know all the ways that we just find
are just subtle ways to kind of
dehumanize this message last week kind
of to dehumanize and distance and it's
like so this Series has really been
about pushing back on all of those
chasms those walls those um boundaries
that we that we put up now
because of that I think kind of um in
the background
um of perhaps some of your minds and it
was certainly on my mind as I read
Richard Beck's book
um has been the question
um
and this is really the title of the
message our boundaries
bad
can you see how this is interesting like
how in ways at times we'll have like a
certain belief
and then we'll start learning about
something else and without realizing it
we're like yeah this is awesome but we
don't quite realize the implications of
this for that
does that make sense
and I think that's this is like a very
key question in this series
um because we may not realize it but in
ways the whole series the whole book is
really kind of posing some very very um
powerful critiques of
um the boundaries that we create that we
make
um
and this is I think this gets really
tricky like for example
um
like morality
um moral what are what are morals except
um boundaries
you know like when you say well I
believe this is right and this is wrong
in that moment what what have you done
like right then right away you already
have a certain Chasm being built right
you have
um kind of all of the dangers that the
whole series has been about it just it's
a slide towards judgmentalism and you
know because there's a certain standard
and there are those who meet the
standard and then there are those who
don't meet the standard and you can see
right like immediately like this is
where it goes and this is the book
unclean uh is
kind of naming look what's happening
look what's happening so that's morals
um but even what about at the level of
um Community think of communal
boundaries so in other words saying um
you know we are we are this kind of
people and we maybe share these kinds of
values we have a t-shirt yeah which I'll
actually get into in just a minute
um
right that says where where this kind of
community we stand for this
um
and can you see that at the very moment
you do that at the very moment you
create a group
well you have people who what
don't fit aren't in the group by
definition
and then all of the problems kick off
that the whole series has been about
like this the subtle impulse to start
kind of dehumanizing like yeah they
really aren't our kind of people they
don't have our kind of values and like
you can just see where oh it just starts
going there
um it's at the level of morals at the
level of um kind of the community
um but even on like the personal
um level actually before I go to
personal let me share um The Story So
back on community
um I had this little awkward moment
every single uh we called our welcome to
the table class it's like our new
members class here and uh so in the
first part I cover our values which you
saw the T-shirt thoughtful inclusive
eclectic communal vulnerable
and so that that one inclusive that's
the key one so I go on and on about you
know we long to be an inclusive Church
regardless of whether it's racial lines
or sexual orientation or gender or class
is a big one you know just we we want to
a diverse and interesting group of
people and we want following the the
doors the church wide you know just hey
everyone's welcome at the table this is
who Christ was right so I go on like 10
minutes and it's you know doing all the
things on those values now then after
that though I transitioned to our
beliefs
and I name
they're excited
I name that um that we are in fact a
Christian Community
we are centered on Christ
we have certain beliefs about who he was
in his divinity and crucifixion and
Resurrection
and thoughts on scripture and you know
and I make it clear as I'm going through
out it's not kind of like if you don't
agree with me on every single one of
these get out of here you know like
obviously there's a certain Spirit of
generosity in that but still
we have like these beliefs you know
they're even on our website
and are these not completely intention I
mean you just finished saying like we
want to be inclusive we don't want those
boundary you know what I mean can you
see the the kind of like challenge here
of like huh I mean does that does not
having those beliefs does not not lead
to the worst kind of
um religious judgmentalism and you know
like all sorts of problems
um or on the level of the the personal
consider personal boundaries and not
only in extreme situations of like abuse
and things like that where you say hey
I've got a set of boundary here I can't
relate to you in the same way I used to
um but even at just like a very you know
kind of
um
basic level like
aren't there times where someone's like
hey can you help me
and for various reasons whether it's
your schedule is already booked or
you're just exhausted but you're like no
you know I mean like maybe you don't say
it quite that bluntly you know you're
like oh I'd love to you know but at the
end of the day you're like I'm sorry no
I cannot help you now we just finished
in the series talking about how what
like what is love love is crossing the
chasms right love really um it's
beautiful it's the most beautiful when
it costs us something when we have to
sacrifice right and so can you see where
if that's what love is
well then how can you be like no
right so in ways the the book it's
really a conversation about boundaries
at the moral level at the communal level
at the personal level
um and
I think I mean honestly it's it's quite
a conundrum
um because
I think in essence as I was maybe
halfway or more through the book I I
could kind of see where this problem was
going to loom and I was like oh no oh oh
gosh what does this mean like in essence
is is this just a big critique of
boundaries and back to the title of a
message are just our boundaries are they
bad
um
I think let me go ahead and just answer
that
um no
nothing is very short and we can just
wrap up like this
um no no I don't I don't think they're
um they're not bad
um
in fact there's I even found a quote
later in the book uh where Richard Beck
just pretty flatly he says it like this
he says um let's just four words I don't
need to read it there will be boundaries
that's it there yep there will be
there will be boundaries uh three things
I know your taxes they're due April 15th
the boy is in my household are
incredibly loud
and there will be boundaries those three
things I know
um now
I found actually what's really
interesting about the the work unclean
is that Vex so he published this 11
years ago
and because of this he's been he writes
on his blog like prolifically
prolifically
um so he has a number of posts where
he's reflecting on the book
and
um I found this one I thought so this is
from his blog this isn't in the book but
he he said this Richard Beck he said you
can't have a community
even a welcoming Community without
creating some boundaries and
distinctions
a community without boundaries like
shared commitments or binding promises
isn't a community
that's worth pondering were I to rewrite
unclean today
I'd have added nuances that push back
Upon A simplistic message that moral and
communal boundaries are intrinsically
bad
I think that's um
extremely insightful that in essence
like the the whole notion we talked
earlier about communal boundaries and we
can see with the book that like well
there's certain dangers there
and yet if you say okay I know the
answer no more boundaries no no more
we're done we're done with those those
just lead to the worst kinds of evil and
scapegoating and judgmentalism and we're
just we got to be done done with those
boundaries like in essence you like have
no more Community like if there's a
community where there is no line at all
no shared commitment to love each other
in a particular way like nothing
relationally kind of binding you
together right it's still similar to a
family if it's like everyone's in our
family literally everyone we treat
everyone exactly the same I parent
everyone's kids with the same level of
energy and time and just as as mine
right it's like are you a crazy person
you can't do that right like that it's
back to bed like there will be
boundaries
um in fact even we know this from the
scriptures like perhaps as we've been
reading this Matthew 9 story over and
over and over
um that are really about Jesus pushing
back on some of the boundaries that the
Pharisees has had created
um
in the same
uh kind of way you might have been
thinking about other scriptures that
actually do talk about like communal
moral like certain boundaries
and you might be wondering like what do
we do with those I want to give you
we'll just jump to like one of the most
extreme examples
um this is from First Corinthians uh
chapter five
answers the Apostle Paul and he's
writing to um in a city
um the ancient city of Corinth and some
church gathered there and so he he says
this it is actually reported that there
is sexual immorality among you and of a
kind that even the pagans do not
tolerate a man is sleeping with his
father's wife
now we don't know exactly that's a
strange way to word it you know like so
his mom is that you know no his father's
wife you know so we don't know is this
like a stepmom you know situation
regardless I think from the kind of
collective groan okay yeah yeah maybe
there's some boundaries yeah boundary
boundaries could be good you know
um but he goes on verse verse two he
says and you are proud
um now this again we don't know all the
details we don't like it's possible
maybe they consider themselves like we
are so inclusive
you know we don't believe in those
boundaries and those judgmental folks
that judge other people's relationships
we don't do that around here you know I
don't know I'm not exactly sure where
they were how they were coming from but
that's the situation he's like what and
you are proud shouldn't you rather have
gone into mourning and here's again and
have put out of your felt ship the man
who has been doing this can you see the
moral social boundaries like yeah kick
him out
now we can debate about like what
kicking out you shouldn't have done that
that's not Christian you know whatever
um but I think the the point stands
that like there's gonna be boundaries
in our in our world in fact I was
thinking of some examples that might tie
a little more closely to here
um here at the table I was thinking like
yes we want to be inclusive but let's
say someone was um like really
struggling
um had a history of struggling with like
pedophilia right and they were here
and they wanted to like serve in kids
ministry
right that would that would just be a
boundary would be like you know what
no
you know they're like well that was 20
years ago it's like yeah I get it
you know
right
um and you could say well what your
website it says inclusive
right and it's can you can you see the
tension
where it's like yeah
but
there there will be there will be
boundaries
um
I was even thinking at a personal level
you know what if I
um you know Pastor Brett asked you to
like to serve in some Ministry or
something like hey we could really use
help
in XYZ you know
um kids ministry it's always kids
yeah we could really use something
and so anyway he was like could you
search and you you know you looked you
discussed it you prayed on it you looked
at your own schedule and life and your
own mental emotional health and you're
like oh my gosh no
I can't
right now would that be wrong like you
just said you're not gonna serve in the
church you don't want to serve the Lord
right well
there will be boundaries
another um
example that kind of ties back in with
something we practice here
um at the table we practice what's
called an Open Table during communion
which will experience in just a bit and
um
at an Open Table it basically means that
everyone is welcome
and that's what we practice we don't
like you know have people go through a
class before they can come to the table
um
we don't kind of yeah check all their
theological credentials or hey how much
did you send this week you know
um
we didn't really we don't do that you
know it's just sort of like hey it's
it's the body of the blood of Christ for
you
and um if there's something in you that
you want to connect with the Risen
Christ then you're welcome to come
forward you know and I think that's been
a beautiful practice of ours I don't
have any plans of like you know going
back on that
um but I want to share uh an example of
where a church had a closed table
and where I actually
um I can see why they did it and I think
it was probably wise
um there's a book it's a quite extreme
example
um some of you know in my e-letter I
shared a link a few weeks back to a
wonderful podcast that um Jamie our very
own Jamie had sent my way and in the
podcast they link um where they talk
about the book torture and Eucharist
uh and this is this is a book by William
Cavanaugh where he tells the story of
the country of Chile in the 19 it was
kind of 70s and 80s and this was when um
it was a military dictatorship with
General Pinochet
and he enacted a widespread
um use of torture in the country I mean
it was a disaster
and it was so widespread that that what
you had was this situation where
people in the same community
could be
the torturer
and the tortured
in the same church
and so the church leaders they had like
a decision to make
and they said you know what
um if there is evidence that you've been
involved in torture
then
you cannot come to the table
and they said because
well for a few reasons one it's putting
a certain burden
on the oppressed
to come forward where it just it just
feels off it's like we're all kind of
Kumbaya here like yes Jesus like the
tortured one
and they said no no no we can't do that
um
so it was about it was about that the
the burden
um and it was the incongruence with the
table itself as I mentioned that the
tortured one of Christ and it was it was
basically just it was setting a boundary
and there were certain steps they could
take to be kind of brought back in that
involved like repentance and like hey
let's get back on you know board
um with the way of Christ and
um you could do that but it wasn't as
simple as just pretending that
everything's okay
when it's not
right now that's a very extreme example
but I think it it's it's naming
something right even if you agree or
disagree that's that's fine but you can
see the point right it's at least worth
pondering like what are the limits what
are the boundaries
right that's that's really the question
now
um
this this kind of brings us to I think a
huge question of like well what on Earth
are we to do like it sort of seems we're
caught between a rock and a hard place
on the one hand you're like okay there
will be boundaries but then you risk
everything we've been talking about
throughout the series
you risk the slide towards you know
dehumanizing others judging them you
also risk that you just keep adding to
the list of like all the things that can
kind of get you kicked out this is like
the danger of the closed table is you
know not only torture but eventually
it's like all sorts of things and you
get this whole culture of judgmentalism
and people trying to measure up and
feeling like spiritual failures all that
you know so it's like okay oh gosh okay
so we want the boundary route and now
it's a disaster but on the other hand as
we've named you can say no more
boundaries we're done we're done with
this in the Name of Christ you know who
broke every boundary done with those
boundaries
and then you get all the problems we've
been naming you know it's like so what
on Earth are we to do
um
Becky actually draw draws from uh a
theologian namir slav wolf
who wrote a book exclusion Embrace and
um he gives I think a real some really
good insight into this so here's this
isn't his exact phrasing um but here's
how I'd sum it up he says this make the
desire to embrace and the will to affirm
the Dignity of every person
the primary that's the key word the
primary focus of your life
in church
keep questions of personal moral or
communal boundaries secondary
what I like about this is it becomes a
matter of emphasis
primary
secondary and I think as you reflect
back for example on the story that we
started with Matthew 9 the Pharisees
right I mean hey is they could say is it
not my right as a religious person to
set boundaries I get to choose who I can
eat with I get to choose who I accept in
my Circle of Care
right and it's sort of like uh what's
what's off about it
what's off is that they've made what
should be secondary
primary
right and all of a sudden when we're
obsessed with the boundaries the
boundaries about like everything's about
the moral the communal the personal
boundaries all the time
and what's happening we're losing our
desire to embrace in essence it's
withering our love
and so I love I think it's such a wise
perspective to say hey at the end of the
day
um keep the Dignity of every person you
meet before you know anything about
their personal moral worthiness or you
know whatever you keep the desire to
embrace them to love them to see the
dignity in the image of God in them you
keep that absolutely primary
first place
and the boundaries can come
they'll have to come
but you've got to keep the main thing
the main thing and when the church gets
those reversed
that's where
we become Fair cycle
that's where we become the worst person
ourselves
I've been um enclosing kind of
reflecting on what all this means and
has looked like in my own life
and um many of you know the the church
we came from
um
we love I love him very very deeply but
we made the decision to be an open and
affirming congregation
um regardless of sexual orientation we
wanted one level of membership
and that was a big part of our you know
our story and um
I've been thinking about the boundaries
between us
you know in both the good and the bad
sense
and um
I think in ways like reflecting on that
journey in those folks I think one good
thing or one beautiful thing is that
um I'll just speak for myself I can't
speak for every person here or anyone
who came from that Community I'll just
speak for myself
um I think I've been mostly not
perfectly but mostly able to um keep the
bitterness
out
you know to keep the temptation to like
other them how could they you know
um
to kind of keep that at a distance
and as I was reading unclean I realized
oh
that's what I think I'm learning to do
is to set the boundary
and yet at the same time say hey
but I love you
and I'm for you and I'm celebrating what
God's doing in your church community
and I'm not saying that the holy spirit
is somehow not active there anymore
but I'm for you
and I really believe anyone from that
Community could come through these doors
and I could embrace them
like not just metaphorically
like literally and here's the thing I've
been back to that church community
visited and I was embraced
how is that possible
um
it's about what's primary and what's
secondary and we've felt the need to
draw some boundaries I'm no longer I
resigned there and if I resigned they
would have fired me
yeah like
why because there will be boundaries
there will be
it's okay
um but keep the desire to embrace to
love
regardless of our Theology and
regardless of whatever like keep it
primary
so as we come to the table of the Lord
tonight
um may it be a moment where we receive
the Embrace of Christ
and also a moment where we get to
reflect who is Christ calling me to
embrace
who in the name of moral personal
communal boundaries
might I have
rejected or kept at arm's length and
maybe some of it was warranted there
will be boundaries
and yet
um
doing that in a way that doesn't wither
our love so as we come forward to the
table to receive the body of Christ
represented in the bread and the blood
of Christ in the wine may it be a moment
where that Embrace can happen
so we do practice as I mentioned an open
table
so if you're here tonight and you would
like to participate you are welcome to
do that regardless of your
denominational affiliation or anything
you're welcome
um to participate if you want to connect
with the Risen Jesus so this is the
table
not of the church
but of the Lord
and it's made ready for those who love
him and for those who want to love him
more so come
you who have much faith and you who have
little
you who have been here often
and you who have not been here long
you who have tried to follow in you who
have failed come
because it's the Lord Jesus who invites
you and it's his will that those who
want to meet him should meet him here
come to the table
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
we're going to close out with the song
it's always been you and I just invite
you guys to think on what we've been
talking about tonight and I just
remember that there's so much grace as
we learn this tension there's so much
grace from from God in our lives and he
never leaves us or forsakes US he's
always with us so you guys join in with
us as we kind of reflect on everything
together
you're welcome to stand if you'd like
[Music]
it's the first time in so long
you are the boys
[Music]
it's always great
yes the walls
[Music]
to the Earth
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
walls to stand around me all this time
my garden
tomorrow
[Music]
all right
there's always
[Music]
thank you so much
my on yes okay thank you so much for
being here tonight
I hope the service blessed you in some
way
um
don't forget hat Creek Burger Company
for dinner right after the service which
is in about five minutes
hope to see you there
um also remember you were not alone
wherever you find yourself tonight I
will be in the back after I'm done up
here and if you would like prayer
somebody to talk to or simply a hug I'll
be back there come see me
lastly if you are comfortable doing so
if you could rise to your feet
I would love to send you out with this
benediction
that I believe is true for each and
every one of you
and as we talk about
othering people dehumanizing
sometimes that starts with
you gotta love yourself
you've got to speak kind words to
yourself
you've got to remember who God has made
you to be and at your core you are love
[Music]
so remember you are a child of God
you are a child of God
this is true on your best day and it's
especially true on your worst day
so as you go into your week ahead with
its yet to be determined highs and lows
and everything in between
go with the assurance that you are loved
you are worthy and you are accepted Just
As You Are
and go filled with God's holy spirit
and the desire to extend these same
gifts
of love compassion and Grace to yourself
and to everyone you come in contact with
this week be blessed have a good night
go to hat Creek for dinner good night
who stood with me in the fire it was you
it will always
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]